[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here
we're talking about Google Plus today
Google+ is a social network not a lot of
people give it a lot of credit but I
talked about MySpace the other day
myspace is a social network but if you
go to a Google search and just type in
Google+ is you get a lot of negative
suggested search results thinking that
people don't really think very
positively a Google+ so right now I'm
just going to give you guys five reasons
what Google+ is awesome number five is
the +1 button it's everywhere you can
even grab a Chrome extension that I'll
allow you to see basically how many
Google+ users have +1 a certain page and
they'll show up in the top corner you
can +1 any page on the Internet so LC
plus 1 YouTube videos images content
just websites and general articles
anywhere and it's basically kind of like
a gauge of how popular or how
well-received something has been in the
Google+ user community WolframAlpha
6,000 Plus Ones The Verge 18,000 plus
one Gangnam style 63,000 Plus Ones
[Music]
google.com 147,000 Plus Ones and
youtube.com 194,000 plus ones nice
number 4 is the people now if you've
been on Google+ recently you might have
heard that it just recently passed 400
million users to sign up but everyone
else to say well Google basically forces
people to sign up for Google Plus now so
practically none of them are active
right well one in four of them about a
hundred million people are active on
Google+ every single day and I'm one of
those so links down below these 100
million people are a ridiculously
awesome community with very high
engagement and if you get any of these
hundred million people to circle you or
to be in your circles they're gonna have
a great time on Google+ it might seem
awkward at first on Google Plus because
barely any of your Facebook friends are
there sometimes no one you actually know
in real life is there but Google Plus is
probably the best social network to just
start meeting new people there are a lot
of sites you wouldn't want to do that on
the Google+ is a great community if you
say that Google+ is a wasteland from
your own personal experience you're
probably doing it wrong like if I were
to follow zero people on Twitter or to
have zero Facebook friends I would think
that those sites are also waste lands
too
like myspace number three is the Google
integration with all types of other
Google services as you know Google+ is
basically the hub for it so you're gonna
see Google+ in like embedded in services
like Google Calendar Google services
like search and contacts and Gmail and
that's all gonna help tie everything
together with your profile and
everything about you on your Google+
profile I forgot exactly who but I think
it was Vic get autre or a very high on
Google VP basically described it as like
a hub for the rest of the Google
services so you they branch out from
Google+ into Maps Gmail contacts
calendar everything else depends on your
Google+ profile so it's just a good
thing to have number two is Google+
Hangouts this is an awesome free service
to Google Plus hangouts are like video
chat it's free it's built into Google
Plus so there's no separate app like
Skype needed and it's basically a way
for you to face-to-face communicate
using a front-facing camera on your
phone or your desktop or anything that
can access Google Plus to talk to other
people with your mind you can have up to
10 people involved and there are also
all types of other services that you can
use with the Google Plus hangouts so you
can all watch a YouTube video together
or you can all wear sweet faces that use
motion tracking on your face to give you
a mustache all kinds of crazy things
that you can use with the desktop and
mobile versions of Google Plus hangouts
it's almost like calling - because
FaceTime before if you have used iOS can
only be used on Wi-Fi now it's used on
solar data networks but it's only two
people Google Plus ten people that's a
huge advantage right there the number
one best thing about Google+ is the app
the mobile app is amazing it's so good
in fact that there is pretty much no
need for a third-party app you go to
Facebook on mobile sometimes you use a
mobile website sometimes you might use a
mobile app but the mobile app especially
on like Windows
and Android they suck really badly the
windows of windows phone Facebook app is
awful the myspace apps are not even
worth trying Google+ app is fast its
responsive it has just about every
single feature you can use on the
desktop which is something that not all
the other services offer you can start
hangouts you can join hangout so you can
+1 reshare comment on posts +1 comments
see who +1 posts see from +1 comments
everything that's available on the
desktop is available on the mobile app
on a tablet and on your phone and that's
probably the best thing about Google+ so
overall you might think that Google+ is
just another social network a lot of
people think oh I don't want to get
forced into signing up for this it must
not be great if you have to force me
into it but a lot of people are missing
that this is actually a really nice hub
for your sort of Google life so the more
Google services you use like calendar
Gmail search the more you're gonna find
the benefits of Google+ so we look on
the bright side you might want to try it
out circle a few people circle me my
link is down below in the description of
this video
+1 the things you like try + winning
this video if you've never cross one
anything before and maybe I'll see you
guys over there thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys later
[Music]
you
[Music]